اسعد الله مسائكم بكل خير مشاهدينا نحيكم
الى بانوراما نناقش ابرز ملفات اليوم وفي
ملفات هذا المساء اتفاق عسكري وبريطانيون
يابانيون مرتقب والهدف رجعوا الصين من جهه
الشرق بصواريخ لماذا يساعد الغرب مع بكين
رغم المشكلات السياسيه والاقتصاديه
والانشغال بمواجهه اخرى مع روسيا في
الموضوع الثاني
من اجل شعبه ام خوفا على شعبيته قبل
انتخابات التجديد النصفيه
وفي الموضوع الثالث رحيل مرشد الاخوان
منير ابراهيم اعلان وفاه شخص فقط
[موسيقى]
كتبت صحيفه فاينل تايمز نقلا عن مصادر انا
لندن
توقيع اتفاقيه عسكريه لتعزيز التعامل مع
واشنطن وتنص الماده على ان الاتفاقيه
ستسهل التدريبات المشتركه والتعاون في
مجال اللوجستيات بين الدول وتضع الاساس
القانوني لتبسيط الاجراءات البيروقراطيه
عند ارسال القوات من دولتنا الى اخرى من
المتوقع المملكه المتحده واليابان عن
تفاصيل شراكه لتطوير طائره مقاتله جديده
بشكل مشترك في ديسمبر وقالت الصحيفه ان
اليابان ايضا في المراحل الاوليه لبحث
اتفاقيه الدفاع مع الفلبين واشارت مصادر
في الفاينال الى ان اليابان في مرحله
متقدمه من المفاوضات مع الولايات المتحده
للحصول على صواريخ
ولا التي ستسمح لها بضرب اهداف في شرق
الصين وقال متحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع
البريطانيه للصحيفه ان المحادثات تتحرك
بشكل ايجابي لكنه اضاف انه من غير المناسب
الان التعليق على توقيع الاتفاقيه
نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفينا من الرياض الى
صحفيه الصينيه اهلا بك ومن لندن عبر سكايب
دكتور فؤاد عبد الرازق الخبير في شؤون
البريطانيه والعلاقات الدوليه اهلا بكمين
واسم حالي ان ابدا معك استاذ عبد الرازق
لي فهم ما يحدث في الواقع امم السؤال
المطروح امم ان هذه الاخبار التي اوردتها
لان اليابان تعمل منذ فتره بعد اتفاقيات
جماعتها مع
استراليا مع الفلبين اليوم تعاقد الجديد
منتظر مع بريطانيا
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ولكن لماذا في
هذا التوقيت التوقيت يحمل اهميه بالغه في
ظل صراعات دوليه تشهدها او يشهدها العالم
ما دلالات توقيت اولا
مرحبا يا استاذ كريم فؤاد الكريم الان
يعني كل هذا يدور في ميدان توازن الرضع
الذي تحاول اليابان ان تقلقه في هذه
المنطقه والجميع يغمز كما قلتم من قناه
الصين هي بؤره كل هذا التحرك هذا الاتفاق
ولو انه سيبرم في شهر ديسمبر القادم الا
ان عليه
يكون عنه في هذه الاونه نظرا لحساسيه
الوضع خاصه في العلاقه مع الصين الجانب
البريطاني في الواقع يتحدث بطريقه خفيه
جدا عن هذا الاتفاق ولا يتوسع في التفاصيل
وكما قال المدن باسم وزاره الدفاع ان
المحدثات تسير به ايجابيه لكنه يرى ان
الوقت غير مناسب هناك همم استاذ كريم
ابعاد سياسيه
رياضيه لهذا الموضوع خاصه من الجانب
البريطاني لان الاوضاع في بريطانيا خاصه
من الناحيه الاقتصاديه اوضاع بالغه
الصعوبه فهل تسمك لها هذه الاوضاع بالدخول
في تحالفات عسكريه او اتفاقيات عسكريه من
هذا النوع همم المؤثر هنا ان السياسه
الخارجيه البريطانيه هي سياسه ثابته في
ماذا تتعلق بعد عدد من القضايا خاصه قضيه
همم حرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه لان الموقف
البريطاني ثابت مهما كانت التعقيدات ومهما
كانت الصعوبات التي همم تعاني منها البلاد
الا ان هناك اتفاقا بين جميع الاحزاب سواء
معارضه او غيرها على ان هذا برد اساسي من
سياسي الخارجيه البريطانيه بمعنى استمرار
الدعم سواء الاقتصادي او الدعم المادي او
الدعم العسكري همم
هذا امر اخر ان ده همم موضوع العلاقه مع
الصين هي علاقه متوتره علاقتي يا باب
للصين متوتره وهنا ناتير الدهون الامريكي
في هذا الدور الامريكي يريد ان يزكي هذا
الموضوع لان
مصدر القوه لديه والاشاره الى هذه
الصواريخ التي تحدثتم عنها يوغندا تضرب
شرق الصين هي من باب الردع وليس من باب
التنفيذ لان هذا امر مهم والاهميه ايضا
تاتي ربما لان الصين عنها على موضوع
تايوان وهو خط احمر بالنسبه لها لا يمكن
ان تتهاون فيه قرب
من همم ايضا يعرض العمليه لمزيد من ال-
ال- المصادر ولكن انها تضل حتى الان في
ميدان توازن الرابع
او قراءه حظرتك استاذ فؤاد
اكثر منه استراتيجيه جديده ولكن قد يقول
البعض بانه اليابان من جهتها ان كان الغرب
يفكر في هذه الطريقه او بهذه الطريقه ولكن
اليابان تفكر بشكل عمليا اكثر سؤال همم لك
سيد همم الهام همم اليابان بين الفتره
والاخرى تعيد صياغه سياستها الخارجيه
والدفاعيه الشامله شهدت ذلك على امتداد
سنوات وهذه المره تسعى فعليا الى امتلاك
نوع من الاسلحه قادر على ضرب العمق الصيني
او اقله شرق الصين هل هذه المخاوف جديديه
شكرا
فبالنسبه لعلاقات الصينيه اليابانيه فهناك
تاريخ لا يمكن اهمال لها وهي الحرب
اليابانيه ضد الصين قبل الحرب العالميه
الثانيه و خلال الحرب العالميه الثانيه
لذلك يعني هناك قصه كثيره بين الصين
واليابان وخاصه يعني هناك تاريخ الاستعمار
لليابان لجزيره تايوان لذلك يعني من
الممكن ان نقول هناك جماعه من سياسيين
دائما تفكر بعاده
السيطره حتى الهيمنه على جزيره تايوان
ولكن بالنسبه لحكومه لجمهوريه الصين
الشعبيه يعني زي ما تفضل اتينا من لندن
يعني قضيه هذا خط الاحمر من قبل الصين
لذلك
نعم سين كاكو همم هذه الجزيره هو حارب جزر
يعني حتى لا نسمي كل هذه هناك حرب جزر
تاريخي همم تاريخيه هذه الحرب بين اليابان
والصين ولكن حضرتك ترى بان هذه الاتفاقيه
قادره ان تكون همم
خطوه عمليه باتجاه التصعيد
همم كلا في الحقيقه يعني انا اوافق على
طيفنا من لندن يعني هذه استراتيجيه
المواصلات التي استراتيجيه لتشكيل تحالف
عسكري همم بين اليابان وبريطانيا وحتى
الولايات المتحده ولكن يعني من الممكن ان
نقول له هذا تكرار تافه لنظريه تحديد
الصين بالاضافه الى ذلك يعني انا ارى
شخصيه او لشيء هناك مواصله للاستراتيجيه
لتشكيل تحاله في العسكريه وبلاضافه الى
ذلك يعني هذا الاتفاق بخصوص يعني الاتفاق
ثنائي بين الصين بين اليابان وبريتانيا
وهذا هذا الاتفاق الجديد اعتقد يعكس على
همم الانخفاض او نقول تضعيف النفوذ
الولايات المتحده في منطقه
ذلك يعني بعد انسحاب بريطانيا من الاتحاد
الاوروبي هناك حاجه من جانب البريطاني
لتوسيع التعاون حتى من مجال السياسي وال
عسكري للدول الخارجه القارعه الاوروبيه
ولكن في الحقيقه يعني نظرا لتاريخ السيئه
اليابان في الحرب العالميه الثانيه كان
هناك تعهدات واضحه من قبل الحكومه اليابان
الى دول العالم بان ال ال سياسه سياسه
العسكريه
المتسارعه اسميت التحالف بالتحالف التافه
منك هذا همم توصيف رغم اننا لا نتحدث عن
مستوى متقدم نحن لا نتحدث عن تحالف نتحدث
فقط عن اتفاقيه حضرتك قرات بانه ربما
قادره ان همم تنقلب الى التعاون مكتمل همم
دكتور فؤاد ضيف يعتبر بانه حتى وان تخطت
همم هذه القراءات همم اتفاقيه جزئيه
وانتقلت الى تحالف فسيكون تحالف تافه حتى
وان شامله بريطانيا والولايات المتحده
امريكيه ما رايه
في الواقع انا احترام الشديد للاستاذ
الهام الصين كلمه تافه يعني لا تنتظر
تماما همم اذا كان لها مفهوم اخر عنده على
هذا الوضع الدول تتحرك في اطار قطط واصدار
استراتيجيات واطار استراتيجيات للسياسه
الخارجيه والسياسه الدفاعيه همم بريطانيا
بتحرص على سياسه الدفاع حتى في مجال
الانفاق تنفق على الدفاع ولا تمثل هذه
الميزانيه وهناك يعني وزير الدفاع قوي في
بريطانيا الى هذا لابقاء على بريطانيا
قويه في هذا الوصول الى اليابان ايضا هذا
امر مشروع في اطار السياسات العامه في
اطار التحصن همم ضد اي شيء يمكن ان يحدث
في المستقبل يعني همم حرب الاوكرانيه
الروسيه ايضا حركت كل هذه
المشاعر لان اثارها امتد الى ما وراء يعني
همم
روسيا واوكرانيا وصارعه ضد الجميع يتحسب
حتى الصين قالت الصين قالت انه ربما يكون
الدور علينا يعني اذا ما كانت الدكتور
وصديق
لما تقول بان حرب اوكرانيا سرعت من هذه
المشاعر قد يقول البعض بان المنتظر ان اا
تبطئ ان تجعلهم يفكرون الف مره لانه
تداعيات الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه نحن
نعيش نتائج حتى اليوم في فواتير الكهرباء
العالم يشكو من هذه التداعيات همم وليس
فقط همم روسيا اوكرانيا وبالتالي البعض
يقول بانه الوقت ليس الانسب حتى ان كان
تصعيدا كلاميا هل الوقت مناسب لمثل هكذا
اطار
ربما لا يكون مناسبه من الناحيه
الاقتصاديه ولكن هذه امور تمشي في خطوط
متوازيه لا يمكن ان تهمل يعني الاقتصاد
يعاني نعم ولكن لم تتوقف لمساعدات
لاوكرانيا لنادي بتواجد السياسه الخارجيه
هناك العاده هم في الغرب في بريطانيا يعني
لا يعرفون من العدو الاول هو الصين ام
روسيا الان
يا تحسين من قبل كان عن روسيا الان اصبحت
روسيا والصين فهد يحتاج الى نوع من
المعامله في هذا الاتجاه اينعم الطاقه
والغاز اثرت اثيرا كبيره
فعلا هذه الحرب والفعل ما اعتمد عليه
روسيا في هذا المجال ولكن هذا سيؤثر طبعا
زياده
ايضا ولكن كما قلت لحضرتك
سياسيه ابعاد استراتيجيه وابعاد اقتصاديه
لهذه المساله ومن هنا يعني دايس هناك
الكثير عن هذا الاتفاق مما يتحدث عنه لان
الناس كما يعني بدا يتساءلون لماذا نساعد
اوكرانيا ونحن نعاني ال- ال- الشعب هنا
اسعار طاقه
ارتفعت 3% وتزيد الى اكثر وقت يؤثر على
موضوع العقارات يعني هناك حاله الركود
الجنيه في اضعف حالاته تقريبا فبالتالي
هناك حسابات اخرى لكن هل هذا يمنع الدخول
في تحالفات مثل هذا الامر والتوقيع عنه
عليه في شهر ديسمبر القادم يعني علينا ان
ننتظر نتائج لكن ليس موضوعا لانه موضوع
استراتيجي يهم ال- ال- بريطانيا اولمبي
اليابان ويهم بالولايات المتحده الامريكيه
حتى قالت ان ان يعني
صدق هذا الامر وتصرف تصريحات قويه في سبيل
ايضا تصريحات من قبيل الرادع بحيث لا
يستمر المساعده
حتى معلقا على التصريحات الصينيه يقول بان
الصين
تمدد ولكن ليست هناك تصريحات تفهمنا
الاطار العام الذي تعمل من خلاله الصين
للردعه على الاقل والفتره همم هذه تستوجب
مثل هكذا تصريحات استاذ الهام ما رايك لان
المشهد اليوم يضعنا امام توترات ويضع
الصين امام همم منطقه همم ربما اي انفلات
فيها يفتح الباب لمواجهات همم مسلحه وهذا
ما يتخوف منه كثيرون
نعم طبعا يعني اول شيء نؤكد على لكل دوله
الحكه
لاتخاذ السياسات الدفاعيه وايضا لها الحكه
لتعاون مع العسكري مع دول الاخرى ولكن
يعني ان اشكركم اشكركم واقدر على سؤالك
فيما يتعلق بان هل هذا التوقيت المناسب
للاتفاق بين اليابان وبريطانيا حول
التعاون العسكري وخاصه يعني
التميميه في التغيرات العسكريه الجديده من
الجيل الجديد الجديده ففي الحقيقه يعني
هذا توقيت وخصوصا نظرنا نظرا لازمه
الاوكرانيه الان كل العالم كل دول العالم
في الحاله من التوتر او من القلق لاندلاع
الاشتباكات او الحرب الجديده لذلك الان
يعني رغم على ان هناك تتلعات لتوقيع
الاتفاقيه وليس اتفاقيه حقيقي بين اليابان
بريطانيا ولكن كان هناك اتحاد اوكوس وايضا
هناك تحالف العسكري بين الولايات المتحده
واليابان
نحن سنبقى متابعين لهذا الموضوع كما قال
الدكتور فؤاد نزلنا في انتظار تفاصيل هذه
الاتفاقيه لانه اكيد ستضعنا اكثر في اطار
ماء سيحضر لكن نناقش كل ذلك في حلقه قادمه
شكرا جزيلا لكم من الرياضه صحفي الهاملي
ومن لندن دكتور فؤاد عبد الرازق الخبير في
شؤون البريطانيه والعلاقات الدوليه شكرا
لكم